[Music]
in almost a year since we all met you
through the through America's Got Talent
do you believe that that's it's already
been that long it's are you kidding me
it was white shorts I mean I feel like I
just got off the show and now I'm here
um did you just super cool I mean I hope
I really hope that it just grows from
here um now what are you most excited
about this show today um
Alysia Cara Noah Cyrus there's just so
many like wasted people there's some big
people here Britney Spears this year
girl look at me start so started really
hope I can meet her but I mean she is
Britney Spears and I'm me so it's a bit
of a gap she might know who you are
puffy bleh you never know though you
have a favorite Britney song hello the
classic hit me baby one more time there
it is
no you give us a little bit of it give
me your side i'll body better pay you
back how's that like I could go on I
don't wanna make it awkward though cuz I
do know every word just song I mean I
would be here while you were while you
were singing that hold on definite
karaoke song it's like my go-to karaoke
oh definitely
no are we gonna see you pop up at all
this season of America's Got Talent
I don't know if I can do you have well
you have any advice for the contestants
because they're doing the audition
process right now um follow your guts
and that most important please live by
this you can be polite and nice but also
know what you want and don't let anyone
tell you otherwise there it is I think
that's very important to know
those kinds of shows to really know who
you are and that no matter what people
say you can be polite and nice while
still staying grounded and saying I
think I want to do this now we've gotten
a little bit of music from you probably
getting a full album soon very very very
soon and a single king another single I
don't know how much I'm allowed to give
away but I'm just so excited I'm working
so hard
everyone's been working for not only me
and like there's just so much time and
effort sweat and tears and awesomeness
of and put into this album I can't wait
for people Eve what's the sound what's
the vibe very campfire ish but still
kind of produced already any collabs on
the album will Taylor Papa Taylor won't
pop up there are collabs though one
o'clock so something something there's
something that'll give you a little